how's it going everybody today we have
our first look at jackin phoenix as the
Joker this official photo was released
and we also have a leaked video and some
leaked photos as well if you're new to
my channel I'm currently doing a
giveaway giving away a copy of Avengers
infinity war it with a special edition
poster and some special memorabilia from
our partners at silk'n coke all you have
to do to enter the giveaway is be a
subscriber like the video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero you can also check
out silk & Co in the link below so start
off chicane Phoenix in this official
photo the leaked video and the leaked
photos is not wearing the Joker makeup
but remember this is an origin story
that doesn't mean he's not going to wear
makeup at all in the movie in fact I'm
sure he will for the majority of it but
again origin story so this is most
likely before he becomes the Joker so
let's take a look at this leaked video
there's no audio to it just really loud
car noises because it's a fan taking it
[Applause]
so what we have here is the Joker
listening to somebody gives off a little
laugh keeps listening some more looks
kind of serious but then laughs again
then he walks over to the person and we
find out it's a clown he walks up to him
gets right in his face takes off his red
nose
throws it down the street then he laughs
and walks away so it's really hard to
tell what's going on in this scene
judging by this video alone but
thankfully there are also some leaked
photos that give us a little bit more
info about it
so in these photos we can see that he is
leaving a building he's going out a door
and on the door it says haha' talent
booking so I'm guessing that the Joker
and this other fine gentleman in this
video are clowns and this is the company
that they work for I'm also assuming
that in the brown bag that he's carrying
is his clown costume what I'm guessing
happened here is he got fired and he's
leaving the place that he used to work
for and as he's leaving he sees this guy
and this guy kind of starts poking at
him starts making fun of them and just
ticks him off which is why he goes up to
him and throws his nose I'm assuming
this and a series of other unfortunate
incidences caused him to snap and
eventually become the Joker as you can
see here in some of these photos of him
laughing when he laughs he does look
pretty menacing so a lot of people were
pretty mad that he's not wearing any of
the Joker makeup but again it's an
origin story I think this is in the
beginning of the movie and I think of
course eventually he will put the makeup
on it would be a huge mistake if DC went
away that didn't have him wear it but I
would not put that past DC to do however
having said that he does look pretty
psychotic without makeup on so if they
do go the route where he becomes the
Joker the full-on Joker with the makeup
and everything I think this could be a
pretty good movie if done right of
course so there you have it our first
look at chucking Phoenix as the Joker
tell me what you all think about it in
the comments below also do we think he's
going to put on the Joker makeup
eventually let me know
your thoughts and again reminder about
the giveaway if you'd like to enter all
you have to do is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Music]